crystal is with us in Kentucky hi
crystal welcome to the show how can I
help ya my husband and I had taken SPU
almost a year ago we've been working
through our debt snowball and he had let
me know that he had some student loans
that have he hasn't touched him in 10
years at all he doesn't remember me ever
making a payment to them um I got a
letter I got a letter about three months
ago from it says that is held by the US
Department of Education for Alliant
capital solutions so I'm curious should
we call them and start a minimum payment
plan or should I just go through my debt
snowball and see if I can take lump sum
and settle some of the smaller account
some of the smaller student loan
accounts yeah there's a couple that are
only like maybe fifteen hundred or two
grand like are you able to settle
student loan debt for less than what was
owed not like you can credit card debt
because it's federally it's federally
insured and they're going to take your
tax return money and they've got the
ability to garnish you you they've got
all these other things that they can do
so because of the federal insurance on
it the bank is going to get their money
so they do not they will not discount
typically the principal amount the
original amount borrowed or the interest
now what you can get waived with some
negotiation sometimes with the lump sum
offer is you know collections fees late
fees and tourney's fees anything like
that you can get all that stuff knocked
off but the interest that has accrued
and the original amount borrowed you
usually cannot get rid of that now if
you can pull it off I don't mind you
doing it but you don't make them an
offer let's see what they do but you
know you need to get into it and figure
out what is really owed and why in other
words if they say hey he owes $2,000 on
this one and he hasn't paid it in
fifteen years you know you know what was
the original amount borrowed what was
the interest rate and how much of this
is late fees right and then see based on
that little miniature audit
what they'll take off if you pay them in
a lump sum but yeah you probably have
some leverage doing some lump sum like
that but like a credit card an old old
credit card like that you could settle
that for you know twenty fifteen cents
on the dollar you're not going to do
that with a with a student loan would it
be wise to contact them like ASAP works
as long as they're not hounding us
should I keep going through my snowball
until I get closer to the student loan
debt I would wait till you get to them
okay
and once they start really hounding us
yeah let sleeping dogs lie until you get
there but but this time you guys got to
combine your finances and deal with it
because the fact that this is how long
have you been married just a year so
we've already actually paid about twelve
thousand dollars in debt so far for you
only we only have about we have sixty
four thousand total including the
student loan debt and how old is this
doing on that is how old is this turd
lump research ten years II believe no
these are ten years okay yeah it's you
know the big deal now is to combine it
own it together and work your way
through it
you're obviously taking point on that
because you're the probably the nerd
like I am at my house I'm the one that
does the math but in your house Rachel
it'd be Winston probably be taking point
on that Yeah right exactly yeah I think
the key here is the fact that he even
said it right because I can be a pretty
shameful thing of like hey I've had to
step for ten years I haven't paid on it
and I've talked to a lot of couples
where they continue to hide the debt or
they continue what we call financial
infidelity and keeping it a secret so
the fact just as encouragement to you
guys that it is out in the open it's
talked about he showed it you guys are
working on it together is huge progress
in and of itself because sadly there are
a lot of couples up there that just
don't communicate about it at all and
it's just like running on two different
paths so if you're listening out there
the quicker you can combine your
finances the faster you're able to work
as a team to get this paid off yeah the
faster you're going to get out and so
Financial Peace University calls that
conversation that's nine-year-old
marriage to deal with a ten year old
Shane yep and that's you're right that
is a painful thing to work through but
the good news is are doing it I'm proud
of you well done